the concept of beauty in who is
considered beautiful
has been a core part of the human
experience for millennia
and it has long affected a wide range of
social outcomes
from partner choices to hiring decisions
to life satisfaction so it's no wonder
we humans have a long history of trying
to optimize our beauty
and arguably that's intensifying in
modern life
[Music]
we are living today in the most prolific
visual culture
in history the obsession with beauty
also stems from
new pressures and new freedoms people
are experiencing in global capitalism
today
many people have more partner choice
than they did before
as urbanization grows and more people
date online
this means that people may be competing
with others
more than before more people are also
working in services
where appearance can be a job
requirement and that can contribute to
body anxiety
given the intense social pressure to
look a certain way
there's no surprise that the beauty
business is booming the industry
is currently valued at around 500
billion dollars in 2019 globally there
were over 11 million cosmetic surgical
procedures
and over 13 million non-surgical
procedures such as botox
of course there is no one way of being
beautiful but every year brings an
abundance of treatments and products
that promise new ways to try and achieve
it
like the notorious vampire facial of the
2010s
also known as the platelet-rich plasma
facial
first a sample of your own blood is
taken
and then the plasma the liquid part of
your blood that carries cells and
proteins
is extracted then injected back into
your face
or in more recent times a range of skin
products containing
snail excretions though neither of these
treatments have proven results
but before you go running into the
garden to interfere with some mollusks
you might want to ask yourself if any of
these treatments and products
actually make you more beautiful is it
even possible to get an objective
assessment as to how beautiful
or not you actually are q's studio is an
australia-based company who claim to
offer just that
using machine learning coovs takes
in-depth measurements of your facial
features
and then shows you how you compare to
others within your own ethnicity
a useful service or downright terrifying
at curves we have a comprehensive report
where we measure your facial features
against scientific standards and then
evaluate how far off you are from the
quote-unquote perfect phase now there is
no perfect face but
generally these standards of scientific
measurement are the ones that plastic
surgeons would use
and so it provides a background briefing
before you go in for
surgery that's what you're interested in
but is this pursuit of perfection
healthy shouldn't we love the skin we're
in
we're providing you with the research in
a nicely packaged way
but we always encourage you to
critically think about your own surgery
and to think about how beauty actually
affects you is it important is it
important enough
to warrant surgery if cosmetic surgery
or applying snail mucus doesn't appeal
to you
there are thankfully some less extreme
ways of optimizing your beauty
[Music]
if you have too much sun exposure uv
exposure this can
cause damage to your skin and the cells
in the skin the dna may
undergo mutations which may eventually
lead to skin cancer
because the uv rays can penetrate deeper
into the
skin they also damage the collagen and
the elastic fibers
that are in the lower layer of the skin
and this is what causes the deep
wrinkles when you're out in the sun for
a long time then you should wear a broad
spectrum sun cream
or clothes that cover your skin to
prevent
that skin damage
lack of sleep can release the stress
hormones which are bad for our skin
also the skin has its own internal clock
and so skin cells are programmed to grow
and repair
at night while we sleep a good night's
sleep can be subjective but on average
it's anywhere between six
and nine hours genetic epidemiologist
tim spector says the role of diet in
conditions such as acne is still unclear
but he believes that keeping the
microbes in your gut in good working
order through reducing processed food
and eating a wide range of fruit and
vegetables should help your skin's
health
generally so in the future we will be
able to tell you
which foods you should be eating to
enhance this particular type of microbe
that could help your skin health
at the moment we we're just giving
general advice
to increase the helpful microbes in your
gut
and reduce the harmful ones you might
think all this beautifying is deeply
superficial but perhaps this pursuit of
beauty
is part of what makes our species unique
the caduveo people in brazil
elaborately paint their faces the nuba
and the sudan practice scarification
that tattoo
a polynesian word is widespread across
the pacific
beauty can have an irresistible pull for
humans
but we are fundamentally different from
other animals and that we do not accept
our bodies as they
are
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell
to get a notification each time we
upload a new video